I want to talk about a friend of mine a
nice old lady named America you see I
love America it's been perfect from the
beginning
ever since the day white people landed
on Plymouth Rock and immediately
invented jazz you know what I have to be
honest I've seen changes in America and
sometimes when I look around I don't
recognize my country anymore first up
glee clubs I know I know
I love them too why because a cappella
music perfectly encapsulates the
American spirit
it's brash it's bold it over does it
with Bruno Mars but now the leftist
ivory towers are corral in these vocal
Cowboys according to Breitbart my
favorite news source that also sells
beer koozies there's a new progressive
policy at Harvard that's forcing male
and female choirs to accept opposite
genders what are you kidding me and
these people want to Domingo with the
opposite gender they wouldn't have
joined a Glee Club yeah I I've said it
before it's Adam and Steve not Adam and
Eve there's a real threat
Breitbart in no way overstates it when
they say because of the Jacobin push for
political correctness Harvard is now
waging war against music itself yes it's
the worst war on music since Bill
Clinton me to that saxophone
I know I know this infuriating
gender-neutral quire's guys and girls
can't sing together what's next the
spice people the backstreet folks who
might be love at Hanson have to
retroactively Lee add a boy to the group
know this country is going crazy am I
even in anymore maybe I'm not maybe I'm
in Madagascar
apparently the world's fourth largest
island and I'm walking under the Bayeux
Bab trees the set of vanilla bean in the
air taking it all the incredible
wildlife the lemurs the frogs and the 3d
animated Penguins that did not deserve
their own spin-off and well you have
half of the world's chameleons or as I
call them the Liars of the lizard
Kingdom I'm exhausted and normally when
I'm exhausted I go to Starbucks
Starbucks is a staple of this country
combining the American traditions of
four thousand calorie liquids and bad
spelling
but gar banjar banjar I will not pick
that up
but take a look at what a bunch of over
woke executives have done to my baby
Starbucks opening gates bathrooms to the
public
Christina Paulson devilís has some
reaction from customers even if you
don't want to buy a coffee you can come
you can hang out you can use the
bathroom it's open to everybody and
anybody everybody and anybody
what's next free health care by the half
and half and who's the barista Bernie
Sanders I don't think so I thought this
was America how dare Starbucks let
anyone use their bathroom I earned the
right to take a weird poop by purchasing
a cake pop at 7:30 a.m. like an American
this new open borders policy will not
stand
everyone should be outraged about this
am i right Christina I have one customer
Larry who comes here every single day
Larry what do you think about this
policy of opening up Starbucks to non
customers that it's really not an issue
who cares
well don't you think that it could
possibly get overcrowded and people are
hanging out and then there's not enough
room I don't understand why you're here
or why people you do care no one in
America hears about this
Larry come on Larry we can't just not
care about this this is it the public
school system I know I know I know where
am I where's that good old-fashioned
American outrage maybe this isn't even
America goddamn it maybe it's I don't
know
Endora and I'm hiking the beautiful
Pyrenees mountain range listening to
people speak in French to the door then
Spanish to the south but me I'm speaking
Catalan because I've decided to just
make the world a little more complicated
than it needs to be hey who cares not me
because I'm riding high in the country
with the highest life expectancy in the
world according to the 2013 global
burden of disease yeah it doesn't stop
there it doesn't it keeps going
apparently American fashion is also
under attack look on the website for the
luxury designer Balenciaga two shirts
for the price of one you can opt to wear
the shirt short-sleeved so the other
shirt drapes in front of you or you can
Don the long-sleeve shirt and then wear
the t-shirt kind of like a cape a 1290
dollar t-shirt shirt before you do the
math I'll save you the time even for two
shirts that's a bad deal
yeah these Spanish fashionistas are
corrupting our American icons a plain T
and a plaid shirt those are the two most
American shirts
it's like Abercrombie murdered Fitch and
is wearing its skin you know when I was
a kid clothes were simple boys wore
suits girls wore dresses and dogs wore
nothing because they're perverts you
come on
is this even America anymore or is it
Estonia
I don't know I love a little Estonian
girl because the country is 54% female
and look at me wearing an embroidered
pot cap and getting ready to be lifted
by a man since wife-carrying is a real
sport they are actually great at it's
that all men are to you Estonians
fleshie ubers come on enough you know
what enough enough I can't even stand it
anymore Chuck you gotta help me out
bring me back tell me I'm not crazy and
I still live in the country I love did
the President of the United States just
meet with Kim Kardashian in the Oval
Office
yeah they talked about prison reform
great and our Millennials still whining
about crushing college debt
homeownership is overrated anyway
Hey and is this very segment the way
most of our viewers learned what Estonia
is yeah this is actually airing on the
trap - oh thank god
Thank You Chuck glad to be home god
bless the US the fight continues
[Music]